F minus g of 2 equals 5, and f minus g of x equals negative x squared plus 3 x
plus 3. Great thinking if you found these two. To find f minus g of 2, we
really just want to subtract the two outputs when the input for both functions
is 2. So we just want to subtract the output of g when x equals 2 from the
output of f, when x equals 2. We remember from before that f of 2 equals 8.
This is the number we get when we plug x equals 2 here. And we can recall that
g of 2 equals 3. This is the output for this function when x equals 2. So we
really just want to subtract 3 from 8. So 8 minus 3 equals positive 5. And then
to find this function we're going to take g of x and subtract it from f of x.
So I've f of x first, which is 3 x plus 2, I'll write that here. Now I'm
going to subtract this entire function g of x. That function is x squared minus
1. So distributing this in negative 1, we'll have 3 x plus 2 minus x squared
plus 1. Remember that this negative sign will change the sign of both of these
terms. Then we just add the like terms together to get this new function.